bonjour bonjour est ce qu'on peut dire
que la crise sécuritaire que connaît
aujourd'hui burkina faso est la cause de
la crise humanitaire tout à fait
aujourd'hui on a une crise humanitaire
d'ampleur au burkina et ce depuis
plusieurs années aujourd'hui on a près
de 3.5 millions de personnes qui sont
dans un des besoins essentiels des
d'humanitaires et les personnes
déplacées donc subissent en fait la
pression des groupes armés non étatiques
ils sont obligés de fuir leur village on
les assiste mais aussi on doit aller
assister plus loin les gens qui n'ont
pas réussi à se déplacer dans quelle
mesure la guerre en ukraine qui a
commencé il ya un peu plus de trois
semaines à tellure aura un impact sur
l'insécurité alimentaire et de se faire
sur la flambée des prix des denrées
alimentaires au burkina faso il est
clair qu'il va y avoir un impact je
rappelle juste que avant même le
déclenchement de cette guerre la
situation alimentaire nutritionnelle au
burkina faso est très très préoccupante
notamment du fait de l'insécurité
certains paysans ne pouvant plus à les
cultiver leurs champs du fait aussi des
mesures sur le kobe de 19 avec des
fermetures de marché de frontières et
maintenant avec cette guerre on est très
préoccupé parce que l'ukraine est le
quatrième exportateur de denrées
alimentaires 30% de l'importation du blé
au burkina c'est la russie et on note
déjà des flambées des prix donc c'est
par exemple 50% sur le 1000 37% sur le
sorgho ça va avoir aussi un impact cette
guerre sur le prix des hydrocarbures est
donc là
les chaînes logistiques
le programme alimentaire mondial voit
d'ores et déjà des délais dans ses
approvisionnements et donc le coût pour
les opérations humanitaires va augmenter
à titre d'exemple il y a deux ans le pam
a acheté 290 dollars la tonne de blé
aujourd'hui c'est presque 400 euros la
tonne certains donateurs noël j'ai ont
indiqué qu'ils devaient réduire leurs
financements pour soutenir les
opérations en ukraine qu'en est-il
d'action contre la faim et vous inquiète
tout à fait on est on est inquiet
pourquoi parce que déjà l'année dernière
le plan de réponse humanitaire qui
étaient environ 600 millions de dollars
a été financé qu'à à peine 40 45 %
aujourd'hui on voit que les besoins sont
en train d'exploser au burkina faso avec
encore plus de populations déplacées qui
sont dans le besoin et on redoute
effectivement que la communauté
internationale les bailleurs de fonds
prennent une décision de réorienter des
fonds vers cette crise humanitaire qui
existent en ukraine et nous nous
appelons la communauté internationale à
ne pas oublier la crise au sahel et
particulièrement au burkina faso qui vit
aussi une crise aiguë humanitaire avec
des besoins importants à couvrir